well for much of the country school
started with coven mandates in the past
but that's not the case for head start
programs it's one of the few education
initiatives the government oversees and
it's keeping outdated guidelines in
place for our nation's youngest joining
us now two mothers speaking out florida
attorney general ashley moody and author
of wake sleepy one lisa kerr thank you
both
for being with us
um ashley i'd love to start with you or
actually let me come to you in just one
moment about what exactly we can do
about this problem but first let's
define this problem if we can
lisa tell me what's going on with these
children still having to cover their
faces
sure so i have four children who attend
head start and it's really more of a
mandatory situation right now
so they're being forced to wear their
masks in the classroom with the
exception of eating and napping what's
the justification lisa
you know i've reached out to the local
site and they said that they were
basically being compliant to federal
policies from the office of head start
office of head start federal policies
ashley let me share this with you this
is a statement head start cover 19
requirements will apply to over 1
million children and 225 000 staff
members and teachers that's to quantify
this problem i mentioned in in the
outset not only do we know you as
florida's attorney general but you're a
mother so first from your perspective as
a mother i mean i can't imagine sending
my kid to school today with his face
covered
well that's why i was so passionate
about pushing back on this in court when
i heard that young children
as young as two years old would have to
mask all day even while outside i told
my team we have to be at the precipice
of pushing back on this we filed suit
not surprisingly because it was unlawful
and immoral at the time
the court gave an injunction
they issued an injunction so in all of
the states where you have attorneys
general that said this cannot happen
we will not allow this insane federal
policy that's going to wreck child
development
to be applied in our states there's an
injunction in place right now in states
where you don't have leadership like in
florida with governor desantis and me in
court
you are left with this federal mandate
out there that in head start programs
and remember what head start is
it's a federally funded early learning
opportunity for low-income families
which primarily helps minority families
and those are the pretty much the only
children now
that are having to mask all day and
those are exactly the children we need
to be looking at faces while their
teachers are speaking understanding and
how to communicate so this injunction
gets in place i push back months later
saying this is not fair to the rest of
the children in this nation where they
don't have leadership to push back on
these insane policies i led an effort by
22 states to
seek
the the federal government say yes okay
this is an unlawful policy we'll stop oh
no
today they are still fighting us in
court
to say we want this policy in place
they're still filing pleadings even
though a judge has said this unlawful
and even though now not only is it
unlawful it's reprehensible to the
well-being and opportunity for these
young children from these communities
you can hear the passion in your voice
ashley here's what they're saying by the
way the department of health and human
services on monday august 22nd 2022 ohs
sent a reminder to all head start
grantees that it will continue with the
same approach and not evaluate
compliance with the mask requirement as
we begin
the new program year lisa you heard look
the primary
the primary demographics that are
affected by this are low socioeconomic
children minority children i don't know
how many those
affect or or describe your family but
regardless your family's been targeted
because of their attendance to head
start programs how does that feel to be
among the very very few left in this
country to be targeted by a policy that
is clearly at this point punitive and
unscientific
so it's interesting because i was
actually
a grant writer for the parent
organization which is how my children
enrolled in head start in the first
place so we were an over-income family
but we're amongst
you know foster
youth and
of course different demographics and so
it's just really interesting to see them
being treated differently
and and truly like where does the parent
go for feedback that's been my main
issue since they enrolled in november of
last year is why does it take
legal action for something to be
modified i really just don't understand
that and we'll find out
hopefully we'll be following along with
with ashley we will find out if legal
action is going to
quite honestly save these children uh
thank you for your efforts uh attorney
general ashley moody and thank you for
being on this this morning lisa kerr
thank you sure i'm steve ducey i'm brian
kilmeade and i'm ainslie earhart and
click here to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis